you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
the most advanced data boy ever created
in the uk
is launched off the coast of devon to
measure the impact of climate change on
our oceans
the small changes making a big
difference in manchester as the city
targets a net
zero future and we meet the people in an
award-winning city
using urban agriculture to protect
against the impacts of climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
and coming up as momentum builds towards
the cop 26 climate meeting in november
i'll be speaking to former president of
the summit claire o'neil
about what might be achieved and whether
the uk government is setting a good
enough example
to the rest of the world but first the
most advanced autonomous boy
ever created in the uk has been launched
off the coast of devon
plymouth marine laboratory have
developed the equipment to measure
ocean health including nutrient levels
and plant life
and to track how climate change is
affecting the seas
dan whitehead was at the launch in
plymouth
[Music]
more than half a million pounds of
scientific kit
is slowly edging towards plymouth
harbour
packed with sensors its mission to
measure the health
of our changing oceans we're monitoring
the sort of standard things like
temperature and salinity but then
importantly we're looking at oxygen
levels we're looking at nutrient levels
in the water
we measure in the amount of
phytoplankton so the plant life in the
water which is the base of the food
chain
and we're also looking at the clarity of
the water ph levels so looking at ocean
acidification
all really key parameters for climate
research
the boy weighs more than three tons and
is nearly nine meters tall
all of it powered by solar and wind
alone
in just a few weeks this boy will be
towed out into the english channel where
it will start collecting
vital data it's taken two years of
scientific work
in the lab to get to this stage this is
the sensor package
that will be deployed on the winch it
has a mixture of fluorometers
oxygen sensors temperature sensors the
boy is part of a fleet of net
zero ocean monitoring equipment that's
been created by the plymouth marine
laboratory
it's one of a kind there's there's
nowhere else in the world at the moment
that does this is what we're going to be
doing
it's a test and a trial but it will also
um
it will also give us results that are
published
on our website and that go on to help
make policy
in the uk and internationally
after the final tweaks to sensors and
monitors the boy will begin
feeding back data from the western
channel observatory
five miles off the coast next month
dan whitehead sky news in plymouth
let's take a look at the day's other
climate news now and soldiers in brazil
will be sent to the amazon in a bid to
limit rising deforestation levels
president bolsonaro has signed a decree
to dispatch troops to several states
including para and amazonas for two
months until the end of august
deforestation in the amazon has been
increasing for several years since jaya
bolsonaro was elected in 2018.
267 million people worldwide are living
on land that's at risk of being
permanently flooded by the end of the
century
a new study in nature communications
suggests the majority of land which is
less than two meters above sea level
is in tropical regions including large
parts of south asia
one of the countries most at risk is
bangladesh where 18.1 million people
live on land that falls below the two
meter level
campaigners are accusing the government
of failing to consider the environmental
impact of its 27 billion pound road
strategy the high court is hearing from
the transport
action network who claimed the
department for transport ignored climate
laws for dozens of new projects
including the lower thames crossing in
kent
transport secretary grant shap says the
strategy will create a safe and
efficient
road network and a glass
sculpture containing antarctic air from
250 years ago
will go on display at the cop26
conference in glasgow
the sculpture will have air extracted
from an ice core which contains
tiny bubbles from 1765.
scientists say that was the year co2
levels
started to increase in the atmosphere
after being fairly consistent for around
10 000 years
in just over four months the uk will
host the most important global climate
conference
in six years cop 26 will take place in
glasgow in november
bringing together world leaders business
chief executives
campaign groups and experts to agree
coordinated action to tackle climate
change
but with covid still a priority for
countries around the world
and increasing controversy about the uk
government's green credentials
there are doubts that any significant
progress will be made
well with me now is claire o'neil from
the world business council for
sustainable development and former
president
for the cop 26 summit so welcome to you
and as you used to be president of cop
26 i'm really interested to get your
perspective
over whether cop can be a success and if
it can
what does that success look like
well i think it has to be so you know
that the whole plan for cop
26 well before covid was thought of was
that this
was the cop where we had to stop talking
and start
acting when the paris agreement was
supposed to come to life and one of the
reasons i
was able to persuade the uk government
of which i should say boris johnson was
a very keen supporter of the idea
to host the cop was that this was a
great way for the uk to show its very
green credentials
it will be a success uh when it happens
we know we know we've got to do this no
more delay
it'll be a success when we can get as
many countries as possible to commit
to the sorts of net zero targets that
the uk led the world in doing
and it'll be a success if we can get the
really big developing emitters
particularly china india russia
and of course the us who isn't
developing country but is the largest
emitter
to be there with very specific uh both
targets and also action plans yes and
yet the uk has been criticized by its
own climate change
advisors for being big on promises big
on those targets but
short on action so do you think the uk
really is leading by example
i do look one of the great things is we
can have this conversation because we
have a committee on climate change which
which very few countries do it was set
up
as a sort of independent view of experts
they've been amazing they give us advice
and we accept it and i know the
government will be listening and it's
true that we've set out these
incredibly ambitious targets and we
don't have the policies to back them up
but i'm confident that we will
um if and one big if if we increase the
amount of spending
in our whole code recovery package to
focus on green items whether it's green
infrastructure green transport
uh retrofitting or building new
low-carbon homes so we've got
to back up the policy with the finance
but we have a pretty strong momentum now
in the government to make sure that we
do deliver on these targets
and you're involved in the push to phase
out
emissions from coal aren't you and i
want to just
show viewers our real-time power mix and
you can see here that
48 49 of our energy at the moment is
coming from fossil fuels so
just how good a job are we doing how
successful is the uk in reducing its
reliance on coal and other fossil fuels
well that's by the way a great real-time
app for nerds like us you can actually
check
the real-time energy mix of the uk and
the good news is
uh we're that fossil fuel is almost all
gas it's almost no coal coal has gone
from being 40 percent of the energy mix
in 2010 when i went into politics
to almost none in 2020 when i came out
and we did that
through a combination of carbon pricing
of emission
standards and a really big investment in
gas and renewables and the point about
fossil fuels is coal has got to go we've
got to make coal history it's the most
polluting fossil fuel
it has terrible dis benefits in terms of
air
quality in terms of health issues and i
set up a thing called the powering past
coal alliance back in 2017 along with my
ministerial friend in canada
and it's become the great um sort of
action platform for countries
city-states and companies
to commit to phase out coal power by
2030.
claire o'neil thanks very much indeed
thank you
the city of manchester has committed to
cut emissions by 50 percent by 2025 and
become
net zero by 2038. it's an ambitious aim
that will require
individuals companies and local
government to all make changes
today an initiative called the nature
takeover has been launched to encourage
people
to live more sustainably and help the
city reach its target
lisa lingard is the community lead at
manchester climate change agency
and told us more about what's being done
so we're here today
in moscow park we've got an amazing
installation
that's really engaging people to come
down and find out about our new
climate change action program called in
our nature and it's about bringing the
community together
to develop climate action plans that
will really get to the heart
of what people need to do in their daily
lives but we're not just asking
people and individuals to get involved
we want everybody to understand the
actions that they need to take but also
what actions others need to take
so we're talking about big ticket
actions actions that are really going to
make a difference for that 50
reduction and that is decarbonizing our
energy supplies
making sure that our energy systems work
on
renewable energy getting people into
active travel
walking and cycling around the city and
becoming
and eating more carbon friendly food
now the latest in our series of climate
diaries focuses not on an individual
doing amazing things
but on a city the world resources
institute
ross center prize for cities showcases
innovative and sustainable ways to make
cities more resilient
to our changing planet and this year's
winner announced today is a project from
the city of rosario in argentina
on the west bank of the paranara river
here's why
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
family
[Music]
that's everything from us for today
tomorrow we've got a special edition of
the daily climate show
bangladesh climate frontline will report
on the impact of climate change in the
country from migration to money
and look at the solutions being
developed that's at the same time
tomorrow here on sky news
see you then